Blake Lively reveals how she dropped the
baby weight the first time I did no
gluten and no soy which seems like oh
that's really easy to cut that out
but you realize your soy and everything
you realize you're eating just like no
processes right so that's basically what
I did no processed foods and then you
know working out but I was still able to
have sugar and and all of those things
it's all in moderation you know you just
have a balance of protein carbs and
vegetables the actress will welcome her
second child with husband Ryan Reynolds
later this year the easier second time
around but when Blake does reveal her
so-called a post baby body this time she
doesn't want to other women to compare
themselves to her it's so celebrated
this is what someone can look like after
a baby and I think that's like the
woman's body after having a baby is
pretty amazing you don't need to be
Victoria's Secret ready right away
because you just did the most incredible
miracle that life has they're offering
you you gave birth to a a human being I
would really like to see that celebrated